the movie hard-loving woman is about the
fact really what some people would
consider crazy you had such an
incredible movie career yeah and then
you kind of said I'm giving that up and
I'm going to devote myself full time to
music yeah you weren't saying I'm going
to be an actor and do music you said I'm
going to throw myself into music for a
period of years and really because I
love it I just know my journey was I
wanted to give to it everything I did
like in my movie career I wanted to
discover who I was as a songwriter as a
live performer and you can't do that
part-time you cannot I do that part-time
especially the rock and roll I do it's
guttural it's exciting it's are there
people who give you [__] because you are
an actor and refuse to accept you as a
rock and roller because you are an
actress first here's I always joke that
because I played the Warped Tour I
played leads in Reading I played all
these festivals and I always likened
myself to the bearded lady
so here we have to go see her meaning I
was I was you're an oddity I was in
Oddity in that one I was female playing
really muscular male-dominated kind of
rock I like your onstage costumes thank
you in the beginning I would wear a
Viking helmet I'm just telling you the
rock and roll show is is like a fever
it's like a something in me it's like
I'm fighting against every negative
thing that's ever held me down that's
what that is when I watch you on this
documentary it seems to me that you
throw not only your voice but your body
into this thing in a way like I was
shocked when you staged off and you
throw yourself into the audience and I'm
afraid they're going to molest you
here's the greatest thing you'd be
surprised by first of all no most of the
time audience is playing nice and it's
it's this big joyous thing and I'm I
feel like a beach ball and they're
throwing me around and throwing me back
to the stage but only a couple shows
were would I have wanted to punch
somebody in the face and that was not
not to say anything bad about my lovely
Italian friends but it was a show in
Italy where they were really grabby and
I was like I'm never going in the
audience there and then another time a
female I was singing this like pretty
little ballad and I go in the audience
and I sing I like getting really close
to people I don't know it's just you're
interactive yeah I love it it's it's
also a reaction against film which puts
you far away from people completely
different type of performance totally
different so rock and roll for me is
that communal connection so I was
singing a pretty little song up close to
people and this girl of girl grabs me
and then puts her hands on my backside
and I stopped singing and I almost uh
got a little bit violent right but I
can't say enough about my audiences
they're so incredible foreign